كلنا نحتاج القدرة على التواصل بمعلومات خاصة دون خوف من أن يتنصت أحد علينا لكن تصميم
نظام محكم لهذا ليس سهلاً في حلقة اليوم من Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي سنتحدث عن كيف أن
شيئاً يُسمى توزيع المفتاح الكمي يمكن أن
يساعد مرحباً بكم مجدداً في Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي في هذه السلسلة سنغطي مواضيع قد تصادفونها في مقرر
جامعي متعلق بالحوسبة الكمية كل فيديو يأتي مع وحدة تفاعلية مرتبطة في الوصف لذا
تأكدوا من الاطلاع عليها اليوم سنغوص في عالم التشفير الكمي التشفير هو دراسة
تقنيات الاتصال الآمن وهذا مهم بشكل لا يصدق لأجزاء كثيرة من حياتنا كل مرة تستخدمون
كلمة مرور لتسجيل الدخول إلى موقع أو ترسلون دفعة رقمية أو عندما تنقل الحكومات معلومات عسكرية كل ذلك يتم
عبر بروتوكول تشفيري ما حتى لا يستطيع المتنصت معرفة أسرارنا لكن هناك توتر هنا كيف
نضمن أن الشخص الذي نريد التواصل معه يستطيع فهم رسالتنا لكن لا أحد غيره يستطيع
تاريخياً ابتكر خبراء التشفير الكثير من البروتوكولات المختلفة لمحاولة جعل رسائلهم محصنة قدر الإمكان
من المتنصتين أحياناً يتفق الطرفان الراغبان في التواصل بأمان على
شيفرة مسبقاً يأملان أنها معقدة لدرجة أن المتنصت لن يستطيع كسرها لكن كما
أظهرنا أشخاص مثل Alan Turing وغيره من محللي الشيفرات في زمن الحرب حتى أعقد الشيفرات يمكن
كسرها المثالي أننا نود إرسال رسائل مشفرة بطريقة لا يوجد فيها أي نمط على الإطلاق
ولا طريقة يستطيع بها المتنصت الفهم دون أن يمتلك أيضاً مفتاحاً عشوائياً سرياً لا يعرفه سوى المرسل
والمستقبل لكن حينها نفتح أنفسنا على ثغرة جديدة كيف يمكننا إرسال هذا المفتاح والتأكد أن
لا أحد يعترضه في عام 1984 توصل Charles Bennett و Gilles Brassard إلى
طريقة لإرسال مفتاح بأمان باستخدام بتات كمية وهي تُسمى الآن BB84 الميزة الرئيسية لهذه البتات
الكمية أو الـ qubit التي تمكّن هذا البروتوكول هي أنها تطيع مبدأ عدم اليقين لا يمكنك قياس
نظام كمي دون إزعاجه اليوم سنبدأ بمثال على شيفرة تشفيرية بسيطة ثم سأريكم
كيف أن توزيع المفتاح الكمي ومبدأ عدم اليقين يمكّناننا من استخدام تشفيرات شبه مستحيلة الكسر
سأشرح لكم بروتوكول BB84 بالتفصيل وأخيراً سنشغله على حاسوب كمي
حقيقي أولاً لنبدأ بلعبة ربما رأيتموها من قبل تُسمى الكريبتوغرام
تُعطون سلسلة من حروف تبدو عشوائية لكن باستخدام معرفتكم بأنماط اللغة
الإنجليزية يمكنكم استبدال حرف بآخر لفهم الرسالة إليكم مثالاً هذه
رسالة سرية بشيفرة استبدال بسيطة فكل حروف R تمثل حرفاً واحداً و M تمثل
آخر وهكذا إذا أردتم محاولة حلها بأنفسكم أوقفوا الفيديو الآن
اتضح أن هذه الرسالة شُفرت باستخدام شيفرة بسيطة جداً تُسمى شيفرة Caesar حيث يُزاح
الأبجدية بعدد معين وفي هذه الحالة 9 فـ A يصبح J و B
يصبح K و C يصبح L وهكذا كلما طالت الرسالة كان من الأسهل
رؤية النمط فمع رسالة بطول التي أُعطيناها شيفرة Caesar أو أي شيفرة أخرى تستبدل
حرفاً في الأبجدية بآخر بسيطة الكسر جداً طريقة أكثر أماناً لتشفير رسالة سرية
هي ما يُسمى لوحة المرة الواحدة مع لوحة المرة الواحدة يمكنك استخدام إزاحة مختلفة لكل حرف في
الرسالة تحتاج فقط أن تخبر صديقك بالإزاحة المستخدمة لكل حرف ليستطيع فك تشفير الرسالة
قائمة الإزاحات هذه تُسمى المفتاح أو اللوحة وتُسمى لوحة المرة الواحدة لأنها تُستخدم مرة ثم تُتلف
إذا استُخدمت أكثر من ذلك ستظهر أنماط قد تجعل التشفير قابلاً للكسر مع تشفير لوحة
المرة الواحدة كل من الرسالة المشفرة والمفتاح منفردين هما مجرد سلسلة عشوائية بلا معنى لكن
عندما تجمعهما معاً ترى رسالة سرية تظهر من الضجيج
لنأخذ مثالاً قصيراً لنقل أنني أنشأت وأرسلت لصديقي مسبقاً لوحة المرة الواحدة هذه والتي عادةً تُكتب
بالنظام الثنائي وأريد إرسال الرسالة I love quantum عندها سأشفر الرسالة
باستخدام لوحة المرة الواحدة هكذا أولاً نحول الحروف في رسالتنا إلى نظام ثنائي كل حرف من A إلى Z سيقابل
الأرقام من 1 إلى 26 مكتوبة بالنظام الثنائي فـ A سيكون 0 0
0 1 و B سيكون 0 0 1
0 و C سيكون 0 0 1 1 و
هكذا والمسافة ستكون كلها أصفار
ثم هذا ما تصبح عليه الرسالة نشفر الرسالة بإجراء XOR بين كل بت في الرسالة و
البت المقابل له في لوحة المرة الواحدة إذا لم تكونوا قد رأيتم XOR من قبل فهي
تعني الأو الحصري XOR بين بتين يكون واحداً إذا كان واحد فقط
من البتين واحداً وصفراً إذا كانا كلاهما صفراً أو كلاهما واحداً فأول مجموعة من خمسة بتات في الرسالة المشفرة
تصبح 1 0
0 1 1 سأترك باقي عمليات XOR لتقوموا بها بأنفسكم لكن المهم هو أن
هذه الرسالة الآن مجرد سلسلة عشوائية من أصفار وواحدات بلا نمط لا يمكن فك شيفرتها إطلاقاً من قبل أي شخص
لا يملك لوحة المرة الواحدة التي استخدمناها لتشفير الرسالة إذاً ماذا تعلمنا حتى الآن بعض مخططات التشفير
أفضل من غيرها وبعضها يمكن استنتاجه من قبل شخص ذكي يبحث عن أنماط في الرسالة
المشفرة لكن مفتاحاً عشوائياً حقاً يُزيح كل حرف في رسالة سرية بمقدار عشوائي مختلف لا يمكن
استنتاجه لأنه لا توجد أنماط في الرسالة الثغرة الوحيدة في مخطط كهذا هي التأكد
من أن المفتاح المستخدم لتشفير الرسالة لا يقع في الأيدي الخطأ هنا يأتي دور توزيع المفتاح
الكمي باستخدام الـ qubit توصل Bennett و Brassard إلى طريقة لطرفين للاتفاق على مفتاح و
التأكد بشكل معقول أن طرفاً ثالثاً لم يكن يستمع سراً بروتوكول BB84 هذا معقد بعض الشيء لكننا
سنمر عليه خطوة بخطوة لهذا الشرح لنستعد أصدقاءنا القدامى Alice و
Bob يبدأ البروتوكول بأن تُحضّر Alice مجموعة من الـ qubit لإرسالها إلى Bob هذه الـ qubit تحتوي على
المعلومات التي ستصبح لوحة المرة الواحدة المشتركة أو المفتاح تولّد Alice أولاً سلسلتين عشوائيتين بنفس
الطول إحداهما سلسلة عشوائية من أصفار وواحدات والأخرى سلسلة عشوائية من X و Z تمثل
الأساس الذي ستُحضّر فيه الـ qubit ثم تُحضّر كل qubit في حالة كمية حسب
مجموعة الأساس وقيمة البت الموضحة في هذا الجدول فإذا كان البت صفراً والأساس Z ستُحضّر
الـ qubit في حالة الصفر أو إذا كان البت واحداً والأساس X ستُحضّره في حالة الناقص إذا
لم تكونوا متأكدين ما هذه الأسس والحالات الكمية فلا بأس النقطة الرئيسية التي تحتاجون معرفتها هي أن
القياسات في كل أساس لها نتيجتان ممكنتان فقط 0 أو 1 لأساس Z وزائد أو ناقص لأساس X
إذا قستم حالة الصفر في أساس Z ستحصلون دائماً على صفر
لكن إذا قستم نفس الحالة في أساس X ستحصلون على نتيجة عشوائية إما زائد أو ناقص كل منهما باحتمال 50%
فقد تُحضّر Alice سلسلة من الـ qubit هكذا حيث هنا السلسلة العشوائية من
الأصفار والواحدات وهنا السلسلة العشوائية من X و Z فأول عنصر في كل من
سلسلتيها كان 0 و X وهذا يعني أنها ستُحضّر أول qubit في حالة الزائد و
هكذا بمجرد أن تُحضّر Alice جميع حالات الـ qubit ترسلها إلى Bob و Bob سيختار عشوائياً بين X
و Z كأساس لقياس كل واحد منها فنضيف الآن بعض الصفوف إلى
الجدول لتمثيل خيارات Bob وقياساته هنا اختيارات
Bob للأسس والقياسات وهنا نتائج قياسه للـ qubit التي أرسلتها Alice أخيراً يستطيع Bob
تحويل كل قياس إلى بت باستخدام نفس الجدول الذي استخدمته Alice لتحضير الـ qubit عندما يقيس
حالة الصفر أو الزائد يُعيّن قيمة البت صفر وحيث يقيس حالة الواحد أو الناقص يضع
واحداً فسلسلة البتات النهائية لـ Bob هي هذا الصف الأخير
لاحظوا أنه عندما تتطابق أسس خطوة تحضير Alice وخطوة قياس Bob فإن بتاتهما ستتطابق
أيضاً لكن إذا اختارت Alice تحضير Z و Bob قاس بـ X أو العكس
فبتات Alice و Bob المقابلة لن تكون بالضرورة متماثلة فطريقة اتفاقهما على سلسلة بتات
للوحة المرة الواحدة هي بالاتصال ببعضهما وإخبار كل منهما الآخر بالأسس التي استخدمها لكل qubit
عندما تتطابق الأسس يحتفظان بالبت وعندما لا تتطابق يتخلصان منه
ففي هذه الحالة سيتفق Alice و Bob على سلسلة بتات 0 0 1 0
0 كيف يحمي هذا المخطط من المتنصتين غير المكتشفين حسناً لنرى ماذا يحدث عندما متنصتة
تُدعى Eve تعترض الـ qubit التي ترسلها Alice إلى Bob هي لا تعرف في أي حالة هذه الـ qubit أو كيف
حضّرتها Alice وبفضل مبدأ عدم اليقين وشيء يُسمى نظرية عدم الاستنساخ لا تستطيع
ببساطة عمل نسخة مطابقة من الـ qubit لتمريرها إلى Bob لو استطاعت لكانت قادرة على
التنصت دون اكتشاف بدلاً من ذلك تخمّن أساساً لقياس كل qubit وتقيسها ثم
تُحضّر مجموعة جديدة من qubit مزيفة لإرسالها إلى Bob هناك طرق أكثر مكراً يمكن أن تحاول Eve
بها معرفة شيء عن الـ qubit لكن لا شيء منها يتجاوز مبدأ عدم اليقين
فسنفترض هذه الطريقة المباشرة لتنصت Eve إليكم جدولاً يصف
تحضير Alice واعتراض Eve وقياس Bob النهائي فالآن عندما
يتحدث Alice و Bob على الهاتف لمقارنة أسسهما سيقرران الاحتفاظ بهذه البتات لمفتاحهما لكن
البتات لا تتطابق وهذا لأن Bob كان يقيس qubit حضّرتها Eve وليس الـ qubit الأصلية التي حضّرتها Alice
إذا قارنوا مجموعة فرعية من البتات في سلاسلهم مع بعضهم سيرون أن بعضها لا يتطابق و
يفترضون أنه كان هناك متنصت وبما أن Eve اكتُشفت سيتخلص Alice و Bob
من سلاسل البتات ويبدآن البروتوكول من جديد لكن لو لم تكن Eve تستمع وتطابقت مجموعة البتات الفرعية
التي قارنها Alice و Bob فيمكنهما المضي قدماً واستخدام البتات المتبقية التي لم
يقارنوها كمفتاحهم المشترك بمجرد أن يملك Alice و Bob مفتاحاً مشتركاً تستطيع Alice إرسال رسائل مشفرة إلى Bob و
Bob هو الوحيد الذي يستطيع فك تشفيرها باستخدام المفتاح الآن بعد أن مررنا على البروتوكول لنجربه على
حاسوب كمي هناك أمران يجب مراعاتهما لهذه التجربة أولاً
BB84 مفيد فعلاً فقط إذا كان Alice و Bob بعيدين عن بعضهما في التجربة التي سنجريها Alice
و Bob على نفس الشريحة الكمية لذا هذه التجربة لن تكون مفيدة لتبادل معلومات خاصة لكنها
لا تزال عرضاً مفاهيمياً جيداً لـ BB84
ثانياً الحواسيب الكمية الحقيقية بها ضجيج فحتى لو تطابق أساس تحضير Alice مع أساس قياس Bob
ولم يكن هناك متنصت لا يزال هناك احتمال ضئيل أن يقيسا بتات مختلفة بسبب أخطاء في
الحاسوب الكمي عندما يقارنان سلاسل البتات للتحقق من المتنصتين يحتاجان بعض التسامح مع الأخطاء قبل أن
يستنتجا أن متنصتاً كان يعبث بهم ويتخلصان من المفتاح بالكامل الآن مع هذه
التحفظات لنبدأ بتجربة بدون متنصت أولاً نولّد
عشوائياً ثلاث سلاسل بتات مختلفة كل منها بـ 20 بت الأولى هي سلسلة بتات Alice
الابتدائية الثانية هي قائمة الأسس التي ستُحضّر فيها Alice الـ qubit
هنا اخترنا الصفر ليمثل أساس Z والواحد ليمثل أساس X القائمة الأخيرة هي الأسس التي
سيقيس فيها Bob كل qubit بناءً على تلك القوائم الثلاث يمكننا رسم مخطط circuit بتعليمات
تحضير Alice وقياسات Bob جميع الـ qubit تبدأ في حالة الصفر فلتحضير الـ qubit في
أساس Z إما أن لا تفعل Alice شيئاً لحالة الصفر أو تطبق gate NOT أو X الموضحة كمربعات زرقاء بحرف X
لحالة الواحد للتحضير في أساس X تطبق إما gate Hadamard التي تأخذ الصفر إلى حالة الزائد
أو gate NOT متبوعة بـ Hadamard لتحضير حالة الناقص ثم ترسل الـ qubit إلى Bob المجموعة التالية من المربعات
في الـ circuit تمثل قياسات Bob للقياس في أساس Z لا يحتاج لتطبيق أي gate إضافية
فقط يقيس وهو ما تُظهره هذه المربعات الرمادية للقياس في أساس X يطبق أولاً Hadamard و
ثم يقيس سنشغل هذه الـ circuit باستخدام Qiskit runtime primitive sampler والمخرجات هي سلسلة بتات
قياسات Bob ثم يمكننا مقارنة سلسلة بتات Bob بسلسلة بتات Alice الابتدائية مع حذف البتات
التي لم تتطابق فيها أسسهما ونرى أنهما يحصلان على نفس المفتاح
تذكروا أن هذا على عتاد حقيقي لذا أحياناً قد يكون هناك بت يجب أن يتطابق لكنه لا يتطابق في هذه الحالة كل
البتات تطابقت لكن إذا شغلتم هذا بأنفسكم قد تحصلون على خطأ لكن طالما الدقة قريبة من واحد
يمكن لـ Alice و Bob أن يكونا واثقين بشكل معقول أنه لم يكن هناك متنصت الآن لنرى ماذا يحدث إذا اعترضت Eve
الـ qubit الآن لدينا circuit اثنتان الأولى تُظهر تحضير Alice واعتراض Eve و
قياسها والتالية تُظهر تحضير Eve للـ qubit المزيفة وقياس Bob
يمكننا تشغيل هذه الـ circuit كما سبق ثم نرى ما سيحصل عليه Alice و Bob عندما يقارنان سلاسل
بتاتهما هذه المرة يحصلان على دقة 6 مكرر وهذا أقل بكثير مما
يمكن تفسيره بضجيج الحاسوب الكمي فيستنتجان أن Eve كانت تتنصت الحوسبة الكمية
معروفة وكثيراً ما يُبالغ في الحديث عن إمكانياتها لحل المسائل الصعبة لكن الاتصال الكمي والتشفير
غالباً يحصلان على اهتمام أقل بكثير رغم أن الإمكانيات التي يقدمها الكم في هذه المجالات
بنفس الأهمية والإثارة اليوم ناقشنا أقدم بروتوكول تم اكتشافه لتوزيع المفتاح الكمي وهو
محصن عملياً من التنصت غير المكتشف إذا أردتم تجربة إرسال شيفرة غير قابلة للكسر مع
مفتاح مُصدّق كمياً توجهوا إلى الوحدة المرتبطة في الوصف
شكراً للمشاهدة وأراكم في المرة القادمة